And we could feel that
their target,
once again,
was the most precarious,
the poorest,
and especially the unemployed.
Here is the speech
well not surprising of a rich government,
uh millionaires,
obviously,
millionaires,
and well, we're interested
rather to defend the interests of millionaires.
And then it attacks,
uh.
In the pocket of the poorest.
That's what's happening
That, as we speak,
there is still 7.4% unemployment,
and what do we do then
to make work more incentive?
Well, here on the other hand,
it's a joke what you're saying,
because I don't know if you believe what Atal says,
if you believe in their concern,
but uh, frankly,
it's the same speeches,
old speeches,
uh,
without taking unemployed,
as it is done there,
obviously it will not respond to the situation.
We know very well that today,
if there is unemployment,
if there is precariousness,
is because companies are laying off,
is because there is 1 race for profit,
to the belief that today
the number of employees is decreasing everywhere,
including in public services.
So uh,
the answer today would even be 1 policy
opposite to the one that is done,
it's useless to take up the same old ideas
,
so we know very well that it's okay
contribute to deplete always the same
and always enrich the same.
So. In fact,
we should discuss a policy
opposite,
when in fact it is,
it's obvious to everyone.
In reality,
is that the money is from the millionaires' beach,
in the beach of the billionaires,
in the range of companies in case 40,
in shareholders' dividends.
So do you have one topic?
Is that where we should redistribute?